this week we will continue our  discussion of energy we will introduce  the concept of potential energy which is  related to the work done by a  conservative force and also the concept  of total mechanical energy which is  defined as the sum of the kinetic and  potential energies we will demonstrate  that the total mechanical energy of the  system remains constant if only  conservative forces are acting this is  known as the principle of conservation  of mechanical energy we will also see  how the work done by any non  conservative forces causes the total  mechanical energy of the system to  change usually causing mechanical energy  to be lost from the system finally we  will see how graphs of the system's  potential energy as a function of  position provide an elegant way of  understanding the behavior of the system  for a given value of the total  mechanical energy